hello so it's steve kaufmann
today i'm going to talk about them a
question that we discuss quite
hotly on our forum at link
i.e. do children learn
languages better than adults for t
ose of  'among you who do
n't know says it's a
website for language learning
you can learn up to 28 languages
n register for f
ee to take advantage of it it
s better to become a paying member it's
much more this 10
dollars a month
finally normally I believe they say
that children learn better
although I recently read a study
done by the ash for applied
linguistics in the united states which
claimed the opposite and if by
reading the study it  is obvious it was
obvious that the studies and research
that supported the study was based on
what happens in classrooms in
formal instruction and it may be and
I would even agree that in a
learning situation  formal in
a class
and when you try to deliberately try to learn
a language
it may be that adults are as
good as able or even more than
children but it is not especially in
the classes that languages it takes tonight I
am going to attend an evening
where we are going to listen to mr matte
ferghana polski male rats
radio stations in moscow that i have been listening to
for six years it is part of my
learning the russian language and
i will have the opportunity to meet i am
very happy and then there will
be maybe 200 Russian immigrants and I
know in advance that most must
speak English quite badly
and especially the oldest the
younger immigrants the 30s 20s to 40s
they will speak  better and then their
children they will speak almost without an
accent or perhaps completely without an
accent like natives we have friends
for example a chinese couple the
parents who have lived here in vancouver
for six years the parents p  speak English very
very badly hardly at all although
they understand a little they go
to immersion school does not subsidize
immersion but there at school
for English it is subsidized by the state
they  go in their pocket because they
are very rich who make no progress
at all while their boy who is 14
years old so who came at the age of 8
he speaks English caminati on the other hand my
grandchildren go to
French immersion school here in vancouver
so it's all school children so
anglophones who learn their
history chemistry lesson anything in
french baho after 9 10 and 11 years old he does
n't speak french very well
they understand  but he does not speak
very well who I believe an adult
motivated that they would go to
immersion school for ten years well they
would speak better so what are the
conclusions
good I believe that statistically finally
if we look at immigrants avoid  it
is evident that in most
if not all cases  the cases it is the children who
speak better either english hopes
french in françois lallemand a demonstration
to import language from a country that
welcome immigrants and why
because the child does not study the moor
deliberately the  child wants to be part
of a group
he wants to become like his friends like the
others and it is this this desire to
participate to communicate
to imitate so without having any complexes
maybe there are children who are
a little  complexed but not as much as
adults and in principle I do not believe
that children and criticize
many men the newcomer there from paou
rats who speaks a little with an accent
because he goes there very quickly he is assimilated
he goes  speak like the others and especially
the child I believe that he is less
inclined to doubt himself whereas the adult and
has less desire to be part of this this
group because he succeeds with the Chinese
and the French here he comes  with all
this cultural baggage I even had a
species  cultural ego he won't let go of
that to become even temporarily
become English Canadians or
whatever so there is this resistance
this resistance is on the other hand the adult
he thinks he is very intelligent in his
language does not at all want to appear
a little stupid
so he has a lot of
inhibition complexes and that is that in principle
most children do not have so
children learn better because they
want because they there
they are not students of  the
language they are simply
small beings who want to participate in
another society another culture
with other ways and he wants to limit
everything that is part of this other
society
but if it is a question of learning as a
low duty I  believe that teenagers
adults can learn
but I think that the interesting
thing in all of this is that in most
cases adults learn poorly
what could be done to encourage them to
learn better in my opinion if I  I
look for example at me personally
and I like to learn languages
day they finally speak them accor
ing to level 2 of skills up to
twelve languages but t
t language was not a foreign lan
uage since in Canada French is
an official language mehr
to the first language that I had to
learn it was French when
I was at school I did not learn finally
I could recite the verbs which
took to be or to have finally etc
but I could not speak  but it was
at the age of 16 when i started to be
interested in thailand
when i wanted to know the people the
french speakers in quebec because it must be
said in the fifties to my
nothing it was two cities the city
English-speaking and the French-speaking city in which
we had very little contact with
French-speaking people, but when I was 16 at the
age of 17 I said yes, I'm
interested in
culture, civilization, films,
music, theater and so on  so when
i wanted  communicate and participate and
become common so appreciate it very
quickly I was able to learn and I
think that's what is important
the advantage of children is that they
are not there to deliberately learn
the verbs the rules  etc
they are they simply want to
participate this press release the more we can
imitate this attitude of the children
that is to say less worrying about
small faults etc and this only
only want to participate press
release press release become like a bath the
better we will learn and become  like
that doesn't mean when
you leave your culture forever
that you abandon your culture me i speak
two men
i stay what i am i am canadian
english lettera most of my friends
et cetera come from my background
but i  every time I learn the
language Chinese Japanese
whatever I try to become them
I want to be Chinese Japanese French
and Russian whatever and that's what
's important that's what
children do and I believe that adults
if they can imitate this way
of learning languages
better to learn for example in my ca
e when I start taking and langu
ges I wil
ially listen and read a lot about the c
untry the language l
culture and it's so that it
enters my brain and also because I
want to learn words and I want to
improve my ability to understand
it's understanding that is the basis
then after when I want to start
speaking  by the advantages finally to
speak well it takes a lot by the ssd
assessment but I do not care so much
about the details of grammar etc
at the beginning to listen to read I do not
need a lot of
grammar notions but afterwards when I want to
speak better  etc
then there I'm going to look at the
grammar rules again that I had
looked at a little but without the
powers reminded me well and well I'm going to
look at that
but there the second time or the third
time  the fourth time I look at
the grammar rules
I already have reference points
because I have been listening to the language a lot
and even after reading quite difficult things
I may go and say
easy things where I know  all
the evils but precisely to be able to
concentrate on certain structures
certain points of grammar which
cause me difficulties but so that I
can really penetrate into the language
penetrate into the culture I do not care
about my faults and I communicate I
speak I  listen I read I want to participate
in this culture and I think it
's a bit if you want and it's a bit
like a trial of the child the child
will not study the grammar rules
the child wants  to understand wants to
communicate and that's it and I think that
's so to conclude I think that in
principle from what we can see
children learn better but I think
that there are aspects of this way
of learning that we  the children that
we teenagers adults we can
limit and here and that's what I
suggest and besides that's a bit the
basic principles of our our
learning system at link here thank you and
I hope you have either  contrary opinions
comments
questions anything say months
goodbye and thank you